let me let me let me pull this story up
because this is relevant to we're
talking about this is a tweet from fox
news
not backing down ukrainian parliament
member on inspiring civilian resistance
we know that we not only fight for
ukraine we fight for this new world
order
actual a quote from um kira rudick and
the interesting thing is there's like
some articles that have kind of framed
it as though she was saying
the camera was a national post they were
like she was saying the invasion would
would precipitate a new world order or
something no she's saying she's fighting
for it but what is she referring to it
in the proper noun sense of the new
world order is or is she using this
phrase as a buzz phrase she heard
somewhere
i mean it's
obviously it's just even if it is just a
fuzz phrase and she doesn't understand a
terrible language especially when you've
already got so many people that are like
oh look at george soros loves this this
is like nato this is this country is an
experimental country created to create
american bases and nato and spread
liberal ideology like terrible language
when you've already got people talking
about all of that
um
it is worth simply talking about the
fact that the the western ideology even
though it's morphed into something else
now what some people would call the new
world order some people would call this
amalgamation of
larger institutions it is constantly
wanting to spread itself to other
countries and ukraine is one of those
countries and if it's just western
values that it has that's great but if
it is getting this
mind worm of all the other things that
is causing america to
you know decay in a lot of ways then
that's that's a problem isn't it i don't
i don't know about um you know the grand
conspiracy of the new world order i know
it's been said by several world leaders
i think george h.w bush said it the
night i think it's the same word as like
the deep state right where it's like it
exists but it's not you know lizard
people it's like there are people that
there are people within the
administration that stay there even when
presidents change and that's very normal
and people can call it the deep state
and they can mean it as lizard people or
they can just be in it i've asked you
here asked alex jones what's the
difference between the deep state and
the shadow government and he was like
the deep state basically the
administrative state the people that get
hired and stay there for 40 years and
they're not elected but they're on the
floor of congress but then the shadow
government is like a secretive kind of
global governance that's in place in
case of nuclear war that's going to take
take control
um that's what alex told me
so so here's the issue i take with this
whole like idea of the new world order
is there's a weird overlap between what
china is doing and people saying like
you know biden is a puppet of xi and
they want to bring chinese-style social
credit systems here but then when it
comes to the russian invasion china's on
the side of russia and opposed to the us
and the u.s is desperate to like it's
like begging china please help us not
only u.s are you talking about this
invasion right now the bank so
switzerland you mentioned earlier
switzerland defied its neutrality
switzerland is the home of the bank of
international settlements which is the
central bank of central banks yep and
now it's fighting on the side of
against russia or whatever
here's what i mean like if there was a
which is it are we is china's influence
expanding around the world and now where
you know democrats went and met with
china and you know these these these
communist party members and said wow
look at the the speed at which you can
build a highway this is one of the
stories we've heard they went there like
how do we do this and now you've got
this happening in the in the west or is
it the liberal economic order that wants
to unify the united states western
nations through nato or whatever the
european union both can't be true right
to a certain degree there can be some
issues that's why i i'm like it needs to
be properly defined what it is it's
china is it or is the grand conspiracy
that russia's invasion was all part of
the conspiracy for the new
how many levels of underwater backgammon
are we playing right exactly or is it
just like make it simple this lady said
something dumb because
she's dumb
you know or is she part of a secret plot
to overthrow it's like the australian
the australian
like health minister that said this is
all about what what was called schwab
calling it thank you lydia world order
thing no she didn't say new world maybe
she did yeah she's like this is for the
great reset and everyone was playing
that and it's like why are you using
these words yeah really they do sound
cool so maybe it could just be it
sounded cool like new world order sounds
cool really cool
and it can also literally just be for
publicity because they they get people
talking about it they go well that's not
how i meant it obviously you insane
conspiracy theorists but now you're
talking
in this mind war that we are in fifth
generational warfare that's what they
want to happen is for people to
accidentally start saying we should do
what that other what they want them what
they want it's hard to believe anything
you watch nothing you watch or read
online it's like is this 12 levels of
irony is this a serious statement was it
a mistake even
watching this war live we always talked
about what would it be like if we had
instagram and twitter and everything
when world war ii was happening and now
we've got it and all we're getting is a
ton of fake information so we've got the
the ghost of kiev who
was actually
it was like a video game simulation
video that went viral
and then um
obviously you had the footage of or the
recording of the 13 people that were
allegedly killed on snake island by the
russian government and like awful but
then the russian i saw rt published an
article saying no we actually took them
captive here's a video of that and i'm
like oh my gosh
there's so much different information
being put out here what are you even
yeah look at look at this hold on hold
on the video showing ukrainian fighter
pilot shooting down a russian plane the
ghost of
kiev clip is from a video game not a
video of fighting in ukraine this is
from politifact
yeah yeah and there were even uh
left-wing articles actually i won't say
left-wing because i don't want to i
don't like portraying it as left-wing
versus what right with russia versus
ukraine because ukraine is actually very
nationalist there are a lot of
right-wingers a lot of people that
support the majority of people are
supporting ukraine obviously this is an
invasion by russia but um
yeah there were
progressive articles saying actually
it's good as long as it's positive
misinformation and the ghost of kiev is
misinformation that is boosting morale
and i can see how there's an argument
for that but also like
no it's still misinformation yeah i
think i think um the truth will set you
free and and we should have honest
information and assessments and
understanding and people should be
motivated by that the problem is
you've got uh
you know i think within the parent
factions you can call it the
multicultural multicultural democracy
versus constitutional republic one side
favors truth and discussion and
pragmatism and one side favors control
yeah the the the multicultural democracy
faction is just like everyone get in
line the majority rules and the
constitutional republic is make your
argument state your case
i think it's like the truth about what
though because i understand why in the
truth but not only are you get to choose
how you want to demand what you want to
demand but you also have to decide what
it is that you're what it is that you're
going to demand about like what is rea
what are these people creating
uh
man this is this is a vague way to put
this maybe i can come back at this later
and be a little more clear do you guys
understand what i'm talking about the
people that are like obsessed with the
truth you're also creating reality so if
you drop bombs on someone yeah you can
speak the truth i i killed a bunch of
people i'm not going to say that
that's not me
theoretical this crazy guy might say um
that was the truth he was speaking the
truth but he was also a violent evil
person so the truth isn't enough you
need to be good as well
um but what i mean now we're talking
about war and what's good in war what i
mean is in the u.s someone says i think
our country should be doing certain
things and i say why do you think that
they say take a look at this information
this historical record and what's
happening right now wouldn't you agree
with me and i'd say you make a really
good point i don't agree on that issue
but maybe there's something we can do
the left says you're racist you're a
bigot um x y and z really happened you
should vote for me on this policy
because uh putin is you know kidnapping
babies or how about you know the desert
storm the woman who said oh they're
killing babies and all that stuff they
lie
to convince you to give them something
the problem with that is
if we're not in the service of function
of of meritocracy of
effectiveness
then
it's just ripping things apart things
are being destroyed yeah exactly if
somebody says i believe we should take
this action for fake reason there's a
good chance they're wrong about that
action there's a good chance it makes
everything worse if someone's got a
really good point to be made and they
give you the evidence for their
decisions you can say i understand and i
agree let's give it a shot yeah i mean
don't trust anyone who says that they're
willing to allow misinformation to
spread if it helps their agenda get
across but because at bottom what
they're saying is
i'm not sure if any of what i'm about to
tell you from my position is actually
true but i do want you to believe it see
winston churchill used to tell the
british that they were going to win the
war but he didn't know it was just
propaganda trying to make it hold on
hold on well if you were a leader in a
military and then your country there's
some war would you not use propaganda no
no there's a big difference between
saying ian if you give me ten dollars
then i'll go save a whale and then take
your ten bucks and go buy a beer with it
there's difference of lying and just
creating propaganda and me saying give
me the ten dollars i will save these
whales and then i try and fail there's a
big difference there oh that's a good
point right but we only knew found out
after the fact the general comes out and
says we are going to win it's like yeah
that's an opinion he's he's like he's
trying to boost morale that i get we're
gonna do it i think what if he knows
you're gonna lose anyways and he's just
doing that like i think this no but this
is the question is there ethical
misinformation like you think about a
kid who's about to die in a hospital and
they're terrified and asking you mom
doctor am i going to die and you hold
their hand yeah you're going to die no
like probably telling them you're going
to be fine and letting them pass away in
their sleep would be the ethical thing
to do
even if it's a lie i suppose
yeah i think um
you know we often talk about the nuance
in information censorship is a good one
there's such thing as good censorship uh
people say censorship is wrong it's
always wrong it's not true at all when
someone's posting like child abuse on
social media yeah sensors should remove
that and the person who posts it
illegal stuff should be taken down
censorship can be good um lying can be
good like you said if there's a child
who's dying and no no good is served by
telling like making the child suffer by
freaking them out then maybe you know
you know the kid's got an hour to live
and you're like don't worry you're going
to be everything's going to be fine your
parents are here everything's great and
then they pass away and it's calm and
peaceful they're not scared so like can
that be used on a mass scale though like
you were saying with winston churchill
like just propagating even even like you
know they use dehumanization of the
other forces because they'd have that
problem with people not pulling the
trigger if they think of that oh if you
went out and you're like telling the
truth um these people are just like you
if you sat down and had a chocolate bar
with them you could talk for hours and
have a beer and they're just like you
who's gonna pull the trigger in that war
it's a tough question oh yeah you got to
use propaganda yeah well this is i think
getting back to sort of the ethical
bedrock here of whether it's ever okay
to lie and looking at this example of a
child who's dying i think there's also
an argument to be made that you can
comfort the child without lying to them
you don't have to literally say you are
going to die or even in that instance
for example if you come from a religious
household you actually believe your
child is going to go to heaven and be
with jesus you tell them that you're
going to go to heaven and be with jesus
it doesn't require that you lie to them
necessarily and so i would say
when it comes to dealing with people on
a mass scale
if you're lying
you are doing something wrong that's
what i genuinely believe yeah i mean
look and i understand that's a
controversial position because there are
a lot of white lies that people accept
that you can't tell fundamentally i
believe that lying is never okay for any
reason so let's let's talk about war for
a second let's say you're going into war
you know for a fact you're gonna win and
you stand in front of all the troops and
be like we're gonna win and everyone
cheers and then you win that's fine and
you tell the truth let's say you're not
entirely sure it could go either way
but you're gonna rally people and say we
will win
and that's different right the idea is
like you have a fighting chance so long
as people believe then if you believe
and everyone's got morale boosted i
think it's fair to say you'll win i'm
okay with that if you know for a fact
you're going to lose
and there's limited purpose served and
you're just sending people to die wrong
no but there are times where they knew
they were going to lose and they said
we're going to stay and we're going to
win and then lightning strikes the enemy
camp and stuff like that has happened
well it's true that you don't know so
they stay here
that's a really important point to be
made here which is that they're they're
you get into an uh an interesting
ethical question
when you ask is it
lying
to say something as if you know it for
sure when you don't i think that's a lot
more complicated i would argue that
telling your soldiers you are going to
win when there's a chance that you're
not going to win could actually
negatively affect your chances because
we're just going to win but if you tell
your soldiers this could go either way
you got to fight really hard to make
sure that we come out on top that could
be better for morale that's a good point
actually and and and you you would say
we're going to win so long as you put
everything behind it exactly this
depends on you don't falter yeah i think
that people perform better when they fee
when they think they're going to win
well people vote for the candidate i
think is going to win just because they
think they're going to win but like
wouldn't there okay so you look at like
the gallipoli campaign showing up on
those beaches and just seeing everyone
slaughtered around you and being told
like you know you're going to win you're
going to win this war and then wouldn't
that like rush doubts through your head
everything i've been told is a lie
everything
for this cause is this why winston
churchill sent us here to die world war
ii like i don't know midway through the
war they decided to invade near italy
gallipoli that's part of turkey uh and
they they just beachheaded it and landed
and it was just a slaughter british and
an australian annihilation yeah
devastation i think you got to be honest
but this is this is the challenge um the
cheaters will lie and the cheaters get
that advantage
and so you gotta hope that i think but i
think a lot of
disadvantage yeah well i would argue
that in the long run lying is a
disadvantage because you end up in such
a tangled web of misinformation that
you're not making decisions based on
reality anymore it does catch up to you
it depends on what your goal is so when
you look at a lot of these establishment
players i feel like most of their goals
is just in individual power
self-interest they want a nice house for
themselves like that blm lady who owns
like five houses or whatever you know
okay whatever you know
they come out and they claim they're
doing all these good things they lie
sure for humanity it sucks it's making
everything worse people burn down
buildings and die but the individual
succeeded in their plan lying helped
them they got what they wanted they
extracted what they could and then those
of us that say you know we gotta be as
honest as possible it's it's it's you
know i'll give you an example
um with the stories that are coming
around the ghost of kiev and snake
island what was i saying the other day
ian about the ghost of kiev i've not
seen any evidence it's a true story yeah
i've not seen i i've seen clips on the
internet of a plane i don't know what
that is it is a cool story it's
masculine it's a hero it's ace fighter
pilot so it's cool it boosts morale but
i don't know that it's true now it turns
out at least some of the footage was not
even real it was from a video game and
so people are like maybe this is not
real it's propaganda and it probably is
the case the same thing happened with
covington when that story came out yeah
people sent me this video and i'm like
it's some kid standing there i have no
idea what this is well look at the kid's
face i'm like what about his face i
don't and so i looked and someone sent
me a facebook live stream show what
happened and i was like i don't
understand the native american dude
walked up to him why are you mad
like people are mine are mindless
towards this stuff they just don't care
they want to believe it
the manipulation
i think with the covington kids really
ended up being very detrimental to media
organizations
but if your goal is just to maximize
your individual profits you don't care
how much damage you're causing to the
system or the country
honesty if you see a video of a jet
flying you'll be like i saw a jet flying
yesterday but no you didn't you saw a
video a bunch of pixels of some some
data you didn't see the jet and so when
we're in the metaverse and we're
experiencing reality what we think we're
seeing we sang with anyway i'm sorry
it's only one angle oh yeah no i just
had a thought that was like you know i
was thinking about your point you're
like people who lie will eventually lose
and i'm like maybe the reason that the
lies are necessary is because we've had
a cultural and moral decay whereas the
lies wouldn't be necessary without that
because you could just tell someone yeah
you know what you might die
but this is a cause worth dying for
whereas today you couldn't people are
like no i i don't want to fight unless
we're going to win like i was saying
about the border guards who don't care
about what's happening at the board yes
there's there's a video that got
released recently of a plane landing at
uh at an airport in i think um
uh what's what's the
what's the westchester is that north of
new york i think it was maybe but uh it
lands north of new york and there's a
federal contractor and there's a cop and
he's like what are you doing and they're
like i don't know we're supposed to do
this and he's like okay well you're not
supposed to but we're gonna let you do
it anyway and then the contractor says
to the cop no one can know we're doing
this and he's like why it's like because
the government's betrayed the american
people those are two guys
that don't care about this country at
all and one's a federal contractor and
wants a cop
that i think is is indicative of what's
happened in this country that you would
witness
a serious crime by your government and
be like
don't care it doesn't affect me
you know i think about these stories i
hear from you know morocco or brazil or
russia about bribing cops
and and they say it's like it's the norm
you're in south america and you get
pulled over slipping 50 bucks and you're
on your way right south african driver's
license it's just like is that what it's
all about they call it a driver's
license in any country you go to where
you can do that but in the united states
you can't do that you try bribing a cop
yeah you're gonna no one would even try
because they know the cops probably
gonna be like you can't afford me and
i'm not risking i got a body camera it's
never gonna happen but there is a
certain degree of of corruption that
we're starting to tolerate and that is
complete self-interest is it is it so
different a bribe right if i give you
cash versus if
you overlook a serious federal crime by
your government because you like the
money you're being given by them
yeah i think we've just got better pr
than a lot of the rest of the world yeah
american propaganda is the best in the
world absolutely thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you